Чотири атаки дронів на російську столицю - і це лише за останній місяць.
Це змушує сумніватися в ефективності російської ППО.
Чи справді вдається "пробити" протиповітряну оборону РФ?
Чому російська ППО не може нейтралізувати дрони,
що летять на Москву?
І чи наростатиме інтенсивність ударів по території Росії?
Причому востаннє - в ніч на 1 серпня -
дрони поцілили у те ж саме місце, що й попереднього разу -
хмарочос у Москва-сіті.
Двічі потрапити в одне і те ж місце - це не випадковість,
вважають експерти.
Насамперед це свідчить про недосконалість
російської системи ППО.
У російського ППО залишилася велика проблема перехоплення
і виявлення цих сучасних малопомітних безпілотників -
по всьому шляху їхнього прямування від території України до Москви.
І помічають їх тільки в останній момент у більш населених районах,
скажімо, передмістях Москви, поліція, ФСБ,
Росгвардія, які тепер, між іншим, несуть цю службу.
Де люди за допомогою своїх очей і вух
бачать і чують літаки чи безпілотники,
які наближаються, і одразу повідомляють.
До цієї війни вважалася, що у Росії ледь не найкраща
система ППО у світі. Це була її головна сила,
і вона досі вважається дуже потужною.
Але той факт, що Україна, якщо це Україна,
може запустити безпілотники, змусити їх пролетіти 500 км
захищеною російською територією і,
якщо не завдати шкоди, то принаймні уразити Москву -
дуже показовий. І це багато говорить про реальні
можливості російської системи ППО.
Ізраїльський експерт Сергій Мигдаль критично ставиться до заяв Міноборони РФ
щодо нейтралізації дронів.
За його словами, у російській армії,
як і раніше, не вирішена проблема перехоплення
безпілотників та українських ракет у районах,
ближчих до українського кордону.
Тому весь тягар повітряної оборони РФ лягає на системи ближнього бою,
наприклад на ЗРПК "Панцир-С1", які захищають важливі об'єкти цивільної
та військової інфраструктури і спрацьовують в останні секунди до
враження цілі. Тому це нагадує лотерею.
Так само експерт скептично ставиться до заяви Міноборони РФ
про начебто "придушення дронів". Придушувати безпілотники,
які пройшли зовнішнє кільце оборони та перебувають над містом,
за його словами, немає сенсу.
У таких випадках дрони краще збивати.
Заяви міністерства оборони не мають жодного сенсу,
коли вони кажуть "придушили" та "впав" на Москва-сіті.
Могло впасти, як ви розумієте...
Це пощастило, що нікого не вбило.
Як ми бачили, там були сильні вибухи.
Одна справа користуватися засобами радіоелектронної боротьби
в пустельній місцевості, у лісах чи степу - будь ласка.
Але над містом дрон треба саме збивати, жорстко,
поки боєголовка не прилетіла до одного з будинків.
Найімовірніше, що російське ППО не пристосоване
до знищення таких видів БПЛА, а військові
не мають досвіду їхнього збивання.
Однак росіяни можуть адаптуватися до таких атак.
Втім і безпілотники так само будуть вдосконалюватися.
Зараз, найімовірніше, була всього лиш розвідка боєм.
Адже, за попередніми даними, в Москві
виявили лише два безпілотники. З часом такі
атаки будуть потужнішими,
вважає військовий експерт Олексій Гетьман.
Поки що ми можемо бачити, що по факту ті дрони,
які атакують Москву, вони не можуть бути знищені
РЕБами, зенітно-кулеметними, зенітно-гарматними,
зенітно-ракетними комплексами.
Ця війна приходить вже на територію Російської Федерації,
вони це мають усвідомити, вони це ще не розуміють,
але усвідомлять. І це невелика кількість дронів.
Мені здається, що це все ж таки була розвідка
і перевірка на міцність їхньої ППО.
І, якщо буде потреба, ми зможемо атакувати
більшою кількістю дронів по якихось військових,
по центрах прийняття рішень, в тому числі,
мені здається, і по Кремлю, і по башті Останкіно,
і по інших місцях. Це вже вирішить наш
Генеральний штаб, які об'єкти на території РФ
безпосередньо в Москві мають бути знищені.
Експерти припускають, що атаки на Москва-Сіті
продовжаться, оскільки, швидше за все, ЗСУ
таким чином "налаштовують" свої безпілотники.
Це випробування в бойових умовах.
Явно вибирають для цього, якщо там насправді,
як я думаю, є оптичні сенсори, датчики,
які можуть помічати великі будівлі, об'єкти
та порівнювати їх із зображеннями, які зберігаються
у нього в пам'яті.
Це дуже зручна мета, ці хмарочоси легко розпізнати,
комп'ютер навчається.
На думку експертів, Україна продовжує пристрілюватися.
У ніч на 24 липня один із безпілотників
майже долетів до штабу кібероперацій ГРУ,
вдаривши в сусідню будівлю Міноборони.
А попереднього разу, у ніч на 30 травня,
поцілив у будівлю одразу трьох міністерств,
унаслідок чого постраждало кілька будівель
і вибуховою хвилею на вулицю
викинуло міністерські документи.
Відразу зрозуміло, що якісь важливі документи.
Схема чого? Витрат!
Та в Україні не підтверджують свою причетність
до цих атак. Проте президент Володимир Зеленський
раніше заявив, що "поступово війна повертається
на територію Росії". А експерти роздумують,
якими дронами могли цілити по Москві.
Враховуючи дальність і шкоду, можна припустити,
що вони схожі на моделі, які вже використовувалися
в подібних атаках раніше. Можливо, UJ-22
чи Mugin-5 китайського виробництва.
Я так кажу, тому що приблизно в той же час на підльоті
до Криму було збито 25 безпілотників.
І немає жодного відео чи зображення,
крім вибуху та наслідків.
Але щодо кримських безпілотників висловлювалися
припущення, що то були Mugin-5.
У будинках Москва-сіті, крім офісів, знаходиться
й чимало квартир. Тож атаки дронів по Москві
безумовно впливають на населення країни.
Після першого прильоту всі казали, що вдруге
в те саме місце не б'є. Коли сьогодні всі прокинулися,
ми, звісно, з охоронцем були трохи в шоці.
Тому поки не знаю, але, найімовірніше,
так, думаю, що буду переїздити.
Я прокидаюся від лютого грому.
Я дивлюся, що дощу немає, грому немає.
І я розумію, що у мене собака забився від страху під диван.
Керрі Чавес, наукова співробітниця Інституту
сучасної війни у військовій академії Вест-Пойнт,
вважає, що наліт безпілотників на Москву
має символічне та психологічне значення.
Психологічні збитки та збитки громадської довіри,
особливо враховуючи цілі, які були обрані
для цієї конкретної атаки, можуть бути значними.
А це породжує сумніви у тому, що Росія
може надійно контролювати та захищати
свій центр, а тим більше лінії фронту.
Ці дрони, два з яких перетнули
Московську область, вдарили по району Москва-Сіті.
Це район, де зосереджено багато бізнесу,
багато багатства, міністерств.
З тактичної точки зору подвійна атака
може відтягнути з фронту до Москви системи ППО.
Інакше владі загрожує невдоволення населення.
Настрій росіян - чутлива тема для влади,
а отже у ЗМІ ці атаки або не висвітлюються зовсім,
або подаються як незначні події.
Утім, друга атака безпілотників на будинок
"Москва-Сіті" змусила російське керівництво
відмовитися від звичної стратегії ігнорування
і визнати, що загроза існує.